there's all kinds of research that shows
that you know trying to block learn
something to nail something down to
listen to it over and over again to read
the same thing again all of this
is not very effective hi there steve
kaufman here again uh today i'm going to
talk a little more about repetition
and i'm going to do things a little
differently because i'm going to answer
some of the questions that people have
given me here on my youtube channel
which i often don't have the time to
answer
individually remember if you enjoy these
podcasts please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications
and if you follow these podcasts on
spotify or
apple podcast or any other podcast
network please make sure you leave a
review
all right so
because there was a fair discussion
about this issue of the importance of
repetition and some questions about it
i was going to answer them and then i
thought you know maybe people would
appreciate having me answer these
questions
in a video so i get a lot of very kind
comments thanking me for my videos and
they get greetings from different places
i won't necessarily respond to those
although i do appreciate them
but where there are questions that i
think would be of general interest then
i will respond to them so
and here are my fancy clickable glasses
again
so excellent content so open and so on
here
via any
he goes on to say
i agree with you uh so anyway
zeitgeist like he goes back and listens
again to the same episodes
and uh since as a zeitgeist
saw his
vocabulary and his uh pronunciation have
improved
so he kind of gets the habits and the
intonation of the native speaker so yeah
repetition works
how much you repeat
is up to you
and i have said that there is this
diminishing return you can't just keep
on repeating you know listening to the
same thing over and over and over again
you have to go ahead in my opinion at
least and in my experience go ahead you
know looking for that new remember this
sort of repetition and novelty so go
forward
uh find new things interesting things
fresh things but then go back to the old
things again and in that way i think the
repetition is really effective however
there are people and i mentioned the
example of this chinese immigrant to
canada who claimed that he listened to
the same cd a thousand times and he had
excellent pronunciation so it is a
function of our willingness to tolerate
tolerate sort of a boredom
all right so
then
uh okay so here it's extremely boring to
listen to limited information a hundred
times it contradicts the main idea of
having fun fun while learning yes
absolutely
not only does it contradict the idea of
having fun
in my experience depending on what
you're doing it for if you're doing it
for pronunciation
maybe if you're doing it to
you know get a better grasp on
vocabulary or structures
there's all kinds of research that shows
that you know trying to block learn
something to nail something down to
listen to it over and over again to read
the same thing again all of this
is not very effective
and we are better off grazing going off
to something else and then coming back
again and going away again and coming
back again and that way we notice more
things we may forget certain things we
come back and we notice them again we're
more likely to retain them so don't
assume that repetition me has to mean
just sitting there and repeatedly
listening to the same thing you may do
some of that
and i think it's very important that we
are in charge of our own learning so do
what you think is worthwhile doing uh do
what seems to work for you what you
enjoy doing and you'll be more
successful
so
uh he has neglected his listening
comprehension that's very common a lot
of people neglect listening
comprehension
are there any strategies you have while
listening well the one strategy is so
someone asked perhaps on on my twitter
account you know if you don't understand
something but you really like the voice
and you really the the whole mood of the
thing grabs you is it still worthwhile
listening yes it is so that can be one
strategy uh i listened to the chinese
seongshan
and i didn't understand more than 40 or
50 percent but it was captivating just
by the rhythm and the voices uh it was
like melody for me i listened to in
japan i listened to showanokiroku
history of japan the showa era and again
i didn't understand more than 40 50
percent but the voice the excitement
these are nude bro
news broadcast
from
you know whatever
olympic games uh in 1960 or whatever it
might be and so
again there is value in that and there
can be value in listening to
uh as i say repetitive listening i find
that if you don't understand or if you
don't have the means to eventually
understand that's less effective so i
will always want to have
my transcripts so
in some cases that means that i go to a
uh
automatic transcription service
and and get that transcript which may
only be 90 accurate but at least it
gives me a chance otherwise this there's
always the same things that i don't
understand so um you know i do some mini
stories which is a lot of repetition
and at the same time i go for more
difficult material but i try to always
get the transcript but i didn't have the
transcript for the seong shang in
chinese 50 years ago and i didn't have
this transcript for showing okidoku in
japan say 40 years ago and i still
enjoyed learning them and i think they
helped me with my pronunciation they
helped moving me forward in the language
but it's not like i understood zero i
understood half let's say
so another thing he says he gets
frustrated okay here's a strategy for
listening don't get frustrated okay
learn to deal with uncertainty vagueness
fog you don't fully understand if you're
understanding even 30 40
that 30 40 is washing over your brain
it's helping you and meanwhile you're
alert to try and at least hear the other
words that you don't know
again ideally if you can get the
transcript you can then go in and look
up those words but again even after
having looked these words up and then
when you listen again
good chance you still won't understand
so learn to accept that that is part of
the process but then
six months later you will look back and
you'll realize that you now understand
so much more than you did six months
earlier
okay so he also loses himself
he says estadiamon is private
uh so yeah when we're listening we're
not gonna no way we can be concentrating
the whole time uh we don't understand it
all at times we're focused uh even the
second or third time we listen we focus
on certain structures maybe
but then we
the mind wanders and that's perfectly
all right because for the period of time
that you are focused for the period of
time that you under understanding
things for the period of time that this
sound in another language is meaning for
you
meaningful
communication in the language
you are learning you are getting the
brain used to the language so
frustration it's a similar comment to
the other person frustration is a bad
thing avoid frustration accept what the
process is if you understood everything
you wouldn't need to learn the language
now
so synaptic solder adheres many things
yeah i mean obviously this is this idea
that the uh what uh you know the neurons
firing together
uh but i i do insist that we also need
to have some things that are interesting
you can overdo
uh the repetition uh you've got to kind
of mix in both
uh
so and these are things that we have to
explore on our own we have to be in
charge i think if we are in charge it's
easier to focus it's easier to be
motivated
uh it's not like something is being
pushed at you
so it's not like you should feel
helpless or frustrated because you don't
understand you chose to listen to that
uh you can choose to listen to easier
stuff you can choose to listen to more
difficult stuff where maybe you like the
voice but you don't understand as much
it's it's i think it's very important
that in all of this for any of these
strategies to work
you've got to feel that you chose this
strategy
you try different strategies you found
the one that works for you you can
listen to what i have to say you can
listen to it other people have to say
you choose a strategy that works for you
believe in it stay the course and you
will improve so maybe i'll just leave it
there and next time maybe i will
organize these so i don't have to go
through exactly picking out the
questions
that i should answer and let me let me
know if you think this is useful i could
go back down through a longer list
of questions and and answer them here
via video rather than answering them by
individually
you know answering them in the comments
section
anyway uh thank you for listening i'll
leave a few videos that might be
relevant to this discussion
bye for now